In this problem, we're given an input string and
the parse chart that was created from parsing that string.
And we're tasked with finding the grammar on which
that token was parsed. So let's look at the problem.
Here we have the given string, and here we
have the parse chart. Our strategy is going to go
through each line of the parse chart and look through
the rules that explicitly appear for the first time. Say,
this one right here that indicates E goes
to parenthesis E parenthesis, is explicitly in the
grammar. Add those to the grammar. Run the
parsing algorithm. And then we're going to see if
using that grammar on this token generates this
exact parse chart. So let's get started. Looking at
chart state zero, we see six rules right here. Each of these six rules has to be
in the grammar because no tokens have been read, and we're at
the beginning of each of them. So let's add those to the
grammar. Okay, here's the six rules we were given in the first
state of the parsing chart. And if we run this through our parser,
we'll see the chart that it generates is not exactly the same.
So we're missing something. Let's keep going. Here, we have the continuation of
five rules. And if you look closely, there are no new rules
here. These are all just shifts of the rules that we found in
chart state zero. The minus comes from the minus, the
plus comes form the plus, and so on. So let's
move on to chart two. Here we go. A goes
to nothing, that's new. A goes to NA, also new. And
lastly, we have the two rule, two rules for NA.
So let's put that into our grammar. If we run
this grammar in our parser with that token, we'll see
that we get the same exact chart that we were given,
meaning that we found the answer.